ho paura
benvenuti a grandissima richiesta
tornano i giochi paurosi ma questa volta
saranno i giochi e cattivi più famosi
coralmente molti di questi già li
conoscete sono molto paurosi e questi
personaggi sono molto strani alla fine
del video per i medici quale è stato il
vostro personaggio preferito quello che
pensate che faccio più paura di casa di
un bel mi piace io noi vivremo pratica
tv
mettetevi comodi pratici e iniziamo con
il primo gioco paolo primo gioco e ci
siamo con stai rehn ha più paura giorno
uno tipo g quale di questi perché si
sono varie pari pali della luce perché
scene inedite tipo un palo della luce
tipo però con le sirene con le mostre
no penso che questa paurissima questo il
jumbo mi facci si sente lontana
eccolo no vabbè immagini vederlo dal
vivo così altre cucine 10 sui miei
pesati dove siamo
siamo in una stanza john giorno c'è
scritto qui c'è scritto di svegliare i
tuoi genitori o che almeno non siamo
soli trovano una torcia siren
e si è la sua testa di sirena che sta
parlando lì c'è scritto qualcosa là
fuori ci vengono porta perciò la
famosissima guerra esploriamo e dobbiamo
trovare i nostri genitori
questa porta sembra chiusa questa carta
sono qua c'è un ma ora al muro qualcuno
li apprezzi qui nel bagno si vede molto
poco scendiamo giù che vedo qualcosa di
il free conferito andiamo al frigo che
sia già scritto qui questo scritto
niente questo è la parte del giardino la
parte il balconcino che dà sul giardino
che adesso usciamo fuori e vediamo cosa
mi è buio pesto scritto scritto tra i
tuoi genitori nel campo dei bottini
giusto per qualcuno in un campo io per
noi c'abbiamo lo vedi da sempre più
inquietante ok se spegniamo la luce si
vede ancora mai visto lo scorso episodio
in cui abbiamo giocato asse col mister 8
il coniglio bellissimi con la bambola
cattiva se non avete visto andate a
vederlo poi ha spento la luce ha detto
no no no no no no non c'è più la luce
succede già preso così eccoci ci siamo
svegliati siamo attenti ma dove siamo
sono andato a farsi ma qui sono certo
imparato non approviamo dirlo ad andare
in questo labirinto di mostrare su
periodi no mi ha tolto via pure alla
lega di carta hai visto no gioielli
quindi noi andiamo
mi sa che si sta avvicinando sento il
rumore
l'approccio di nuovi tool che dovremo
decidere quanto è pauroso un gioco in
base a quanti pur li facciamo se voi
volete potete contare il numero di urli
che facciamo più li facciamo più
spalletti forse siamo sarri è chiusa
perché magari questa è la casa di sky
runner
ok allora devo via da qui li sentite le
sirene di dirlo ho preso di nuovo verso
bene queste raffaele ed se volete che lo
continuiamo scrivetecelo nei commenti il
numero di paura da uno di essi di url io
direi un bell 8 e mezzo passiamo al
prossimo prossimo ecco lo lanciò lo
vedete sai questa volta seguendo una
foresta
eccoli massa non piacevano potevo farlo
dando scattando dice che c'era una
troupe che stava filmando che hanno
sentito un rumore strano e hanno visto
queste creature gigante due persone sono
bari
l'esercito ci ha chiesto di andare in
missione e cercare di catturare queste
creature in modo tale che queste vengano
studiate gli si stanno chiedendo che
cosa sono queste siren ed sono animali o
sono creature sono mostri che cosa sono
con il così detto ci stanno lanciando a
noi dall'elicottero vede paracadute
maria test prende tutte le armi per
catturare siren e dubai
allora guardiamoci intorno che sono
queste abbiamo già un arma queste sono
delle camere pare quasi una scuola allo
scudo diamo se questa volta riusciamo a
prendere sawyer il mezzo stessi prenderà
nuovamente sempre come nell'altro gioco
ma no dov'è lo ha attaccato con questi
serie mezzi vanno molto più veloci sono
due sandra non si sa bene se diamo
un'altra arma io direi di prendere la
sposa è costato qualcosa come arrivati
ad aosta che scappa so mai dove dove lo
sto riguardando qua preparati con lo
fanno per me lo dicono ma non posso
raffaele un led 2 la stessa
difficilissimo numero di urli di rating
cioè era meno inquietante fernando
batteva il prossimo prossimo dove se lo
chiedete molto spesso ed è cartoon cars
quindi praticamente un gatto spaventoso
a me ricorda un po band ovvero vede un
po inquietante vediamo iniziamo a
giocare nuovamente tutto buio
ah ok fino adesso si vede un po di guida
è sembrata e mi fa paura se c'è un pò
intorno nella notte stellata e non
sbaglio correggetemi se sbaglio perché
voi sapete sempre tutto chi ha creato
cartoon kept anche creato siren infatti
sembra simile e dicono che ai runner
ebbe cartoon che facciano parte di una
leggenda siano state create
lascio la porta qui questa è la scusa
eccoci siamo nella scuola si è scritto
dobbiamo stare assieme
ecco qui c'è qualcuno che questo non ha
fatto in tempo a leggere cosa c'era
scritto dove jack dov'è andato devo
trovarlo allora trovo panico mi mette un
cat forse ha preso il getto il nostro
amico quindi dobbiamo ritrovarlo ma
abbiamo un gomitolo gli no perche
sprecato risvegliandosi corri corri
abbiamo convinto a ritornare teniamola
losco attaccato che non si vede niente
no mi sembra rifiutare qualcosa mi è
sembrato di vedere un gatto è la porta
ok dove dobbiamo andare dove trovare un
genio
eccolo è lui chiama la palla ma ha
rallentato un po per pochissimi febbraio
sono riusciti che parlano riuscito a
fare continuità che non fosse ciganda
perché corre con le mani dietro jack
dove si dà o ma enorme che cos'è questa
la mente alcune gigante ma che ci sta
inseguendo come lo vogliamo qui oltre a
cartoon cat c'è anche cartoon dog hanno
fatto anche il cane inquietanti e di
tipo come cartoon cat però il cane ma
come facciamo a trovare jack ma almeno
qualche indizio non c'è niente qui
auguro che riproviamoci nuovamente
dentro la scuola
no abbiamo già jack qui vicino a noi
abbiamo ricominciato daccapo with the
market di fatto prendere due volte
aiuto io sappiamo soprassa temi sopra
c'è anche un piano di sopra
c'è qualcosa anche noi stupido niente ho
fatto non si può dire ok andiamo a
vedere se troviamo questa chiave da
un'altra parte
aspettando il piano di sotto si è così
allora jack
l'ultima volta che prendo certo non ti
fai prendere subito bene questa è la
khartum detto il numero di urlare dice
che urli il prossimo among us versione
paura eccoci qua una mappa in 3d sembra
come quando abbiamo giocato ad
allungarsi timori di velo riguardante la
commercialista andate a vederlo c'è un
quadro di un nostro collega con la tuta
blu lega un crew mail security per terra
ossigeno 90 100 per cento
che bello vedere la mappa di among us
quando è successo
bene visto che siamo sopravvissuti per
10 6 tomi proviamo stuhr bible la luce
come in sogno non è disponibile
problemi con classe fate perché dobbiamo
sbrigarci a muoversi non possiamo fare
le cose ha detto padre allora facciamo
poter trovare c'è scritto che è
pericoloso allontanarsi da qua al mondo
dietro il pericolo esterni e l'altro
corridoio questo corridoio dice che
anche il quale pericoloso
non voglio che vi ricordiamo forse lo
devo a cadere ciao vendita che allora
l'impasto el abbiamo chiuso di là quindi
perché richiedono anche qua e poi li
mandiamo recarci del computer che
qualcosa andava al computer e che
aspetta qua c'è un bottone clicchiamo
questo bottone che ho fatto da camera
non so forse ora possiamo passare è
tolto l'illusione perchè no e questo era
uno dei giochi a monza store
quante urla e gli diamo dire il perché
non succedeva da voi continuano gli date
ora passiamo a lungo blocco che lo
stesso mons
oro che cosa gli hanno fatto questi
poveri fiume mi hanno messo gli occhi è
la bocca con i denti
ok eccoci qua siamo in una navicella si
cucina le sembra che siamo dentro a una
nave cambia leone chao pin frigioni ci
siamo già fantasma altri bastare le
porte così cioè le sbarre
ok nel tempo quindi sbriga matrone
questa squadra che invece non si può
passare lasciamo fuori da qua c'è
qualcuno che sta mangiando le mani c'è
il compagno del napoli ciò che gli occhi
di fuori
questa sì che è inquieta anche diamo un
gatto ma ci sta seguendo forse siamo noi
gli impostori
forse non dove riavvicinati
si sentono delle voci su qualcuno che
sta parlando
che brutto questa volta
come devono tornarsene al mattino presto
locali ma si riferisce forse dobbiamo
prendere un arma che ci saprà cos'è
questo un cellulare wow prendi no non ce
l'ho fatto nel primo processo
ma cosa ci fa ora dedicata recate a casa
visto che questo già un altro cellulare
ma raccogliamo i solo perché dobbiamo
raccogliere gli oggetti vedi ecco
finalmente vivo cardiologo che il
governo di questo gioco non si capiva
niente come facciamo adesso è uscita da
qui lo bloccavano passaggio ok proviamo
l'ultima cosa prendo i progetti siamo
lieti che abbiamo visto prima quindi
forse se dobbiamo prendere gli oggetti
posso prendere anche questi oggetti qua
qui c'è un telefono hanno quindi i
telefoni dobbiamo prendere forse sì a
prendere 10 telefoni e allora uno
l'abbiamo presto allora forse è meglio
se non scendiamo giù perché sono bici
blocca la morte parliamo le altre strade
guarda qui c'è un altro preso abbiamo
già due
ok allora maggio si possono bloccare la
porta passato di fianco che in quante
urla dialogo
chi urla ci sono 24 ormai si fa parte
qual è stato il vostro gioco preferito
il mio cartoon castel thun il mio gioco
preferito invece è stato cybernet 27 un
bel mi piace ora vi lasciamo con salini
da indicare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite
una visione